dmt is a really interesting example so
uh terence mckenna has talked about
these machine elves
right and there's this um i think
from the people i've heard speak about
the experience there's a sense that you
are traveling elsewhere
to meet entities whether they're elves
or not
so in your sense you're not traveling
elsewhere
you're just revealing something that's
within and maybe it's a
a particular mechanism of revealing
what's already within
yeah and i knew terence i spent a lot of
time talking with terence and
i do not um ascribe to a lot of things
that he was saying he
was tremendous entertainer and i think
he did a lot of really good things and
focused us on
you know the power of psychedelics but i
think um i've never seen these quote
machine elves
um i think culture is more
determinative of what people experience
under psychedelics
your preconceptions then
then we give it credit for and so i
think there's a lot of
priming that you could say that people
receive by
stories from their culture um
you know with ayahuasca it's about
jaguars and amazonian animals and
so i think these machine elves are this
uh
construct of um terrans that that other
people
do see um there's actually some people
that um
are very interested in doing a study and
they're
well they're and moving toward it to
keep people on an iv infusion of dmt
for them specifically to see do they
contact
machine elves or aliens and what kind of
information do they bring back from
these other
cells uh other places or other entities
um it one question is you know who are
we
are are we um connected to everything in
the universe
we certainly know in many cases you talk
about waves or particles
you know the quantum approach so
i don't interpret um
experiences that we have of some entity
that's
you know somehow or other deep in our
consciousness that's
not us it's a part of who we are so i
tend to interpret it in that way
the the question is how big are we
yeah i mean that that's uh and how many
ideas are within us that can be revealed
by changing the perspective you
mentioned physics one of the
what physicists especially mathematical
physicists or mathematicians do is
the they reveal truths by looking at a
by taking a slightly different
perspective on a problem that reveals
the simplicity
of how it actually works in totally new
ways
that's what einstein did that's what
like every progress in physics
and certainly every progress of
mathematics requires you to take a
different perspective
and then perhaps that's exactly what
psychedelics are doing it's not that
they're contacting
aliens that are elsewhere it may be
revealing the connection between us and
other living life forms
or actually might be revealing
a totally new perspective on what life
is or what consciousness is
uh and giving us a glimpse at that even
though our cognitive capabilities are
limited
in to fully grasp and understand it so
it's just giving us an inkling of that
somehow
and it seems perhaps a little ridiculous
not
from a scientific perspective in the
sense that
we don't have a good physics of life or
physics of intelligence or
physics of consciousness but getting a
glimpse of that
it's giving us a little bit of um maybe
an intuition of
uh which way to head to uh
to build such a physics yeah
yeah i think so i think that there's
this um
other concept i guess i would like to
talk about briefly this
jungian collective unconscious this idea
that
somehow or other everything that has
ever happened
um is still accessible maybe not with as
much
data or as much resolution
but that there's you know wave
resonances
so that i do believe that we can have
experiences as part of this human
collective unconscious
that we're not from our own life yeah
and that that we can uh it's like the
holographic realities and that
that there is a way to gather
information
that can be accurate about other times
and places
through depth investigations of our own
consciousness
but i think what what i tend to believe
is that
it's because there's emotional
resonances between where we're at now
in this life and you know
other kind of
[Music]
experiences that people have had before
and you know
we always hear about uh everybody who
talks about past lives they're always
kings and queens
you know yeah so i think that's you know
that's again you filter
things what you want to be true but but
i do think that there is a way
to access information beyond what we've
taken in
in our own temporal existence through
our own five senses
in some ways i really find that
compelling the notion that that
information is already there
and you're simply just moving the
attention of your mind
to different parts of that yeah i mean
we we have that with the radio
i mean you know you've got a frequency
you turn all this information
you could actually say right now between
the space between us we have the whole
world's knowledge that's up on the
internet
yeah it's right here yeah but we just
have to tune in
you